what's that believe nation I want to
give you some free stuff and I need your
advice on how to do it let me give you
the backstory this is all because of the
YouTube algorithm one of the things that
they are heavily prioritizing is what's
being called view velocities so the more
a video gets views in the first 48 hours
it really the first day that really
helps YouTube decide should we promote
this video more or not and so it really
helps is getting subscribers involved to
watch the videos and these comments and
engage the chair and so I want to try to
figure out a way to make YouTube happy
to make me happy and to make you guys
happy all at the same time what I'm
thinking of doing here we have I don't
want your advice it's not concrete yet
so I need your feedback what I'm
thinking of doing is having some kind of
daily contest so what I want to do is at
midnight Eastern I have three videos
that I split up every day what I want to
do is look at each one of those videos
and look at which comment that's been
left on the videos has the most thumbs
up and then I also want to give a prize
away for whoever has the most believe
worthy comment what I want to avoid is
just people commenting for the sake of
commenting I mean that'll help that'll
help with the algorithm if you come and
watch leave a comment but it's just blah
blah blah that'll help but I don't want
to just fill the videos with comment
spam I want good comments I want to
believe worthy comments and so it's
trying to encourage people to leave
solid comments that gets uploaded and
whoever has the comment with the most
thumbs up at the end of the day or that
day across those big videos get some
kind of prize and whoever has the most
believe worthy you know it's just a
positive uplifting believe kind of
comment they get a prize - so it's daily
prize for two people the videos that
we've launched that day I want to know
what do you guys think and I want to
know what kind of prizes you would like
to see let's let's keep it realistic
okay let's keep our prized expectations
realistic but I'd love to know your
thoughts I mean the overall goal is we
need to get as many people as possible
to the videos within the first 24 hours
I've been going up and I want to make it
in a way that isn't super cheesy and
provides value to everybody involved and
so that was the best way that I thought
of and I'd love to get your feedback so
again across the three videos that we
put up with that day at midnight I look
at which video look at all the comments
those encouraging your leave comments
watching videos leave a carbine a potful
arm an interesting one whichever video
whichever comment has the most thumbs
ups for the day get surprised and
whoever has the most believe worthy
comment as judged by my team will also
get a prize two prizes every single day
let me know what you think let me know
if your other strategies review velocity
I'm always curious about that and then
let me know what those prizes should be
and what you think of the overall
strategy I want to make something again
that fits well for you and you're happy
with and it's a fun the fun challenge
and the fun data game and I can give
back and provide more value to you as
well to the prizes let me know I want to
give you free stuff leave it down the
comments below and super excited to hear
your saying thank you guys so much for
watching as always your loyalty I love
it it means the world to me
I hope you have a great weekend I
believe in you open continue to believe
in yourself in whatever your one word is
much love see you soon